uh welcome back to uncensor Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu talked
tough on Iran in a new interview telling
uncensor regular Douglas Murray that
Iran is bent on domination and Conquest
he framed Israel's ongoing war with
Hamas as a battle between the west and
Iran before warning that Israel will
fight on as long as it takes alone if
necessary come to President Biden warns
the US will respond after three American
soldiers were killed in a drone strike
by Iranian back militants on a US base
in Jordan Donald Trump meanwhile says
we're on the brink of World War III free
is he right what you want me to discuss
all this is the conservative talk show
host and author Dennis Prager and the
Democratic presidential Challenger Jen
yuger welcome to uh both of you Dennis
Prager um a lot of jungle drums beating
now about the potential of a massive
escalation in this war in the Middle
East uh because of these attacks uh
killing Americans because of Biden's
comments and because of Iran's General
saber rattling uh what do you feel about
what is happening here
I don't believe Iran wants a hot war
with the United States I believe that
Iran wants to to use people to kill
Israelis to kill Americans and see how
far it can go thus far it has been able
to go pretty far and there was a Great
Wall Street Journal editorial on this
that there is a sense that the American
president is much more interested in
avoiding conflict with Iran than in
fighting back against Iran so I I don't
predict a a a violent war with Iran
however it is accurate to say that there
is a World War now and there has been
for quite a while between the west and
those who hate the West Iran hates the
West the islamist world hates the West
not every Muslim the islamist world as
opposed to the Islamic world and the uh
people like Hamas hate the West Israel
is attacked for being an outpost of
Western civilization in the Middle East
it's fascinating that that is an attack
one would think that that would be
praise since Western Civilization has
been the most decent civilization ever
created in human history but it is used
as an attack by those who hate the West
the left not liberals the left and the
islamists and they are in alliance
against Israel and the United States all
right uh Jake yuger um I want to play a
clip from this interview between Douglas
Murray and Benjamin nety where he talks
about the war will take as long as it
takes let's watch
this we have to win in Gaza we have to
achieve total Victory Hamas cannot be
left standing coming out of the ruins
with a V sign and saying we'll do it
again and again and again what I say to
our American friends whose help I
appreciate a great deal I said uh the
war will take as long as it takes but it
will result in total Victory because
this our battle is your battle and our
victory is your Victory as well now Jake
I saw today that one of his cabinet was
suggesting that they believe
25% of Hamas terrorists have now been
killed and 25% more wounded and so in
their estimation 50% of the enemy has
now been effectively taken out of the
battlefield ad you think that is
probably true and B what do you make of
what Netanyahu said about this
effectively whether people like it or
not they're gonna finish this
job yeah so I'll address the propaganda
first there's no way of confirming any
propaganda that comes out of Israel
those are madeup numbers but let's
assume for a second that it was true
okay so you've taken out half of Hamas
and killed 26,000 some OD people does
that mean are you're going to kill
another
26,000 how many Palestinians is America
supposed to help you murder for your
nonsense objective which never made any
sense in the first place which leads me
to the second part nyaho says two absurd
things uh one is an effort to avoid
accountability he keep kept saying to
Douglas over and over again oh in terms
of what went wrong on uh me not
defending Israel on October 7th when
they needed the defense not offense not
killing random innocent Palestinian
civilians but actual defense he says oh
we'll get to that accountability after
the war okay when is the war going to be
over he says well we have to have total
Victory what does that mean you have to
kill every member of Hamas well that
everybody knows that's impossible so oh
look at that he set up an impossible
standard for the war to be over so that
it's never over and we never get any
accountability and finally uh the idea
that America should fight Israel's war
for it is absurd no hard no we should
send no money to Israel going forward to
kill innocent Palestinians or as long as
they do the occupation and now they're
dragging us into a giant war in the
Middle East that they're going to ask us
to pay for both in Blood and treasure
there's no Americans that are actually
in favor of that other than
neoconservatives that dragged us into
Iraq and that debacle over there so my
answer to Netanyahu is a hard no no way
do I want to go to war with Iran to help
your political career Dennis Prager do
you think Benjamin Netanyahu is long for
this world as the leader of Israel
because he's so unpopular domestically
the polls have never been worse for him
um you get a feeling of somebody where
the war is almost his last stand as
leader and in a very cynical way if he
stays in it long enough and can claim
victory over Hamas that might be his
only way of maintaining
power it's hard to imagine another
Israeli leader acting
differently there is this perception in
the west and I'm neither a Netanyahu fan
nor a Netanyahu opponent but it is hard
to imagine an Israeli leader who would
say you know Kamas butchered our people
on October 7th raped our women burned
families alive want to destroy us want
to kill every Jew that they can find uh
but we won't respond militarily uh there
in in Israel there is virtual unanimity
there may be discussed with that man
individually I have no idea the British
kicked out Churchill after World War II
uh people are very fickle about their
about their political leaders so I have
no interest in what the poll are all I
can tell you is I can't think of an
Israeli leader who would be acting
differently yeah I think that's probably
true um J youo I want to talk about this
disturbing report which has come out
about the United Nations relief of Works
agency where there were murmurings about
potential involvement of some of their
members in what happened um we've now
seen a Wall Street Journal investigation
which seemingly establishes uh from a
dossier actually the New York Times as
well an Israeli intell dossier uh
alleging that 200 workers uh from the UN
rwa are Hamas or Islamic Jihad
operatives uh didn't provide detailed
evidence the dossy also alleged that 12
workers crossed into Israel on October
the 7th with the Hamas terror group
unrwa has sacked nine of those employees
and says it's investigating another
report by The Wall Street Journal citing
it also Israeli intelligence dossier
alleges 1,200 of the unrwa 12,000
employees in Gaza have links to Hamas or
Islamic Jihad now I'm sure your first
response will be well I'm not going to
believe Israeli intelligence dosses but
the fact that the
unrwa has already sacked nine of these
people suggests there's a clear problem
there yeah so there's two different
issues here Pierce so uh first you're
right I don't believe Israeli propaganda
they say oh trust us there's hundreds of
them no I don't trust you at all uh the
IDF and the Israeli government
have an enormous track record of lying
on almost every occasion related to this
war but okay so you say there's nine
folks who've already been uh terminated
and that's fair and that's definitely
true so obviously there must be some
evidence okay great fantastic I want
accountability I don't want anybody
involved in the October 7th attacks and
they've been fired if you want to do a
further investigation to see if anybody
else was involved and you want to fire
them terrific no problem but that's not
the real issue here the real issue is uh
the right-wing Israeli government hates
this organization because they help
Palestinians there's now half a million
Palestinians that are starving and the
only people that are helping them is
basically this organization and Israel
thinks now their right-wing government
thinks well look if we can eliminate the
one organization that's helping
Palestinians they'll starve more that
way when we bomb them and we kill them
and we starve them there'll be no one to
help them so that'll help us with our
ethnic cleansing when we try to push
them into Egypt which several cabinet
ministers including their national
security minister have now said that is
what they want to do which is of course
ethnic cleansing 101 so they're
targeting this group to try to eliminate
its funding and it's working brilliantly
the Western Powers don't actually want
to help the Palestinians so they're
using this as an excuse to Target the
whole group and one last thing that
gives you a stark example of it let's
say that there was nine people or even a
couple hundred people inside Israel who
helped Hamas on October 7th it's not
impossible there could be collaborators
right so does that mean we should get
rid of funding for all of it Israel it's
an absurd idea when you apply it to
Israel but somehow it's not absurd when
you apply to this organization from the
United Nations of course it's absurd
they should keep the funding but fire
anyone who was involved Dennis pry your
response to miss
St well first let me just say the idea
that is Israel wants to starve the
Palestinians is vile it is it is another
left-wing atrocity on language like
Israel is committing
genocide genocide has been raped like
the word racism has been raped every
decent term has been denuded of its
meaning by people on the left not by
liberals I always draw that distinction
but by people like Chen they have raped
the word genocide they have raped the
word racism they have raped the word
sexual attack all all the evils have
been removed from their context Israel
has no interest there are five times
more Palestinians today than there were
in 1950 it is the worst most ineffective
genocide in the history of genocide it
is a vile smear the United Nations
stinks the United States should leave
the United Nations with every other
democracy it is a place where the Human
Rights Commission has been headed by
Iran where you have uh Iran even heading
the Women's Rights Commission it is a
terrible organization the United Nations
is to Nations what the university has
become to education it has become a
moral Cesspool it is time for America to
leave Jane your response
finally yeah I mean I this guy is
hilarious uh did he say I rape
words yes you rape words I I know you
find that funny it isn't funny yeah I do
yeah I think uh first of all that with
what you've done then by your own
definition is rape of the English
language and rape of the word rape uh
let alone the fact that uh of course you
know you say oh the left says racism
anytime anybody criticizes Israel what
do you guys all say anti-Semitism have
you raped that word that's not true
that's a lie we say it about those who
want to destroy Israel not criticize
Israel it is a complete lie okay so let
me address the United Nations sure sure
sure uh so look the United Nations is
all of the Nations and and right-wingers
like Dennis don't want want us to work
with all the nations they don't like
peace they don't like the world
Community they say we're the ones who
write we're the good guys and Netanyahu
said this in the interview that you uh
display we're the good guys they're the
axes of evil and what is the only answer
for evil War so and that's another thing
that the United Nations is trying to
prevent war and so uh the
neoconservatives like Dennis Prager and
others go no no no no no United Nations
people working together we hate that of
people that have different opinions than
us we hate that people who are for peace
we hate that the only answer is war war
war war of course they don't like the
United Nations so what are we supposed
to do not have a United Nations we're
all just supposed to hate each other
forever never work together don't even
coordinate don't even communicate just
go to war forever and ever this is
insanity and by the way end the
occupation I'm the only candidate that
wants to end not funding for Israel not
just to for this war but for the
occupation which is the core evil to use
the words of Dennis Prager and it is an
indisputable evil that Israel is doing
there and Israel doesn't have to do it I
believe Israel can be a great and
peaceful and flourishing country but
they must end the occupation Jen for
america.com okay gentlemen I'm going to
leave you there thank you for Spiritual
debate I appreciate
it